you'll never be me Wendy you'll never be
me you don't have my wit and you don't
have my talent that's it that's the end
of the story that was Howard Stern
slamming Wendy Williams on the Howard
Stern Show in March well now it looks
like the two are ready to forgive and
forget in case you missed the drama it
all started when Wendy said some not so
nice things about Howard and his new
book Howard Stern comes again on her
daytime talk show Howard is so Hollywood
right now that this book is gonna be
this is what you command how would I
love you but since you've gone Hollywood
everything that you say is so
predictable
every story is gonna be about you know
oh I love this one and then we went on
their yacht and he's a Hollywood insider
now which sucks
because you're you started like me being
of the people but at some point you sat
behind that microphone for too long and
now you are the people Howard Stern took
offense to her comments and went off on
Wendy in a profanity-laced tirade on the
Howard Stern Show worried about your
husband not me gone sick of her her Boat
Show and if you thought that was ugly
just wait till you hear what he said
about her appearance and health issues
remember this is before she came forward
about her addiction relapse and marital
issues oh you dumb show and your mystery
illness she disappears for two months
nobody knows why and now she's
questioning me thanks honey and guess
what I never fainted on my show either
Skeletor just shut up but in a new
interview with The Hollywood Reporter
Howard says he regrets what he said so
much that he's removed the ranch from
future airings of the episode quote that
was me at my worst I thought she was
saying that I was a piece of and I
sucked but as I hear it now I don't see
it as an offense at all if Hollywood
means I've evolved in some way and the
show has changed then yeah she hit the
nail on the head Wendy later addressed
Howard on her show I saw that you
mentioned me and that you apologized
Howard you know what if you never
apologize to me ever in your life you
would still be one of the most
influential people shaping my career you
and Oprah and that's
he said he loves me he met I might have
seen something in him that that maybe he
didn't see or something like that look I
love him he's and my heart was so broken
was fighting with me because I wasn't
fighting with him exactly